graham windram was fighting against the
floodwaters to save
his home his 25-ton barge washed onto
the riverbank
in great barford search and rescue
helping him to get it back into the
river
and try to secure it there with all his
belongings
on board it has been a christmas like no
other
i've been quite happily moored there i
live there obviously so
i go to work every day so getting on and
off the boat's been fine
the last two days i had to uh basically
abandon ship
and uh we've had to make precautions now
today
to uh steady the boat for when the
levels drop
you can't see anymore where you would
usually have the banks of the river and
then the fields and
people's gardens and actually if you
drive round this area
it is a similar picture just this
enormous
sea of water and that is why people over
the last couple of days have been urged
to leave their homes of course here they
are still living in tier four
but the police and other agencies say
people need to take whatever precautions
they have to
and not risk their lives from christmas
eve the waters have been rising along
this stretch of the river gretu's
with 1300 people urged to leave their
homes
one of three severe flood warnings in
place with another two
in northamptonshire it was the center of
bedford that was causing concern first
thing
many say it's not been this bad for over
20 years
on christmas night locals dug these
trenches to keep the waters back
jan schofield lives over the road and
says it was like the community spirit of
lockdown
kicked in once again everyone rallied
around last night from about
six o'clock all the way through to three
o'clock this morning
people local neighbours were digging the
trenches
bringing sandbags some guys with big
trucks came and pulled out the huge
trees that you can see over the road
which were getting stuck underneath the
little white bridge the newnan bridge
and that really cleared the waters
people were staying awake all night
obviously not knowing whether it would
come over the road
for those in charge of the response
covid has had to be at the front of
their minds
and they say it still should be for the
rest of us
please don't be heroic please
follow uh the guidelines do not do
anything that's not
a prayer and also hoving's not gone away
this hasn't just suddenly
allowed kobe to disappear bedford's
figures remain
absolutely high overnight large parts of
the country are expected to be hit by
high winds and heavy rain as storm bella
moves in
the potential impact unclear as many
still deal with the impact
of this christmas disruption rihanna
mills
sky news